okay let me ask you a question what  celebrity do you think is a ton I'll be  honest with you give me give me one  please please don't make this  complicated I'm not gonna make a  complicated but I'm not gonna lie to you  okay I know you answer the questions and  I'm here to answer but I can't I'm not a  celebrity I'm not a fan of somebody okay  let me ask someone  someone raise your hand if you can give  me give me okay Rihanna Rihanna do you  feel like you're as pretty as Rihanna do  I think that's pretty yeah  um I wouldn't compare myself to Rihanna  um because I just wouldn't I don't look  at other girls and compare myself you  see this is this like honestly I'm not  even trying to be rude you just proved  my point is that women are delusional  yeah yeah  I'm not even saying you're not like I'm  not even trying to insult your looks  it's just it's Rihanna